you want to make money next 30 days then
you start a bis Dev show so let's use a
business as an example okay let's say
architectural firm so let's say it's a a
company here in Toronto if you already
have an existing business and you
already know your ideal referral lead
sources so you launch a show where you
go and you have people who are in
Toronto who are all your ideal referral
Partners so you're going to call all of
the institutional lenders say I'm
starting this new show talking about
architecture in Toronto I'd love to have
you as a guest on my podcast and then
you go and you film an episode with them
because if you're an architecture firm
you knew all of the institutional
lenders in the city hey I'm starting a
brand new show if you're trying to go
and get the rock on your show then okay
that's going to be a problem but you're
trying to get project managers and
institutional lenders do they want to
sit and talk to you over coffee about
how you might partner together no
they're being pitched all the time but
will they come on your podcast would
they come on your show and talk to you
about architecture in in Toronto like
yeah you want to hear my story let's
go so Evan carmichel best known of
course as the YouTube Master we were
trying to calculate before we started
recording and I was like 4 million subs
and he's like nah and I'm like 5 million
n 6 million he's comfortable with saying
almost 7 million Subs across all your
channels whatever you don't even care
about it once we crossed a million it
was it was a big deal yeah and then
hdden two and three was we did a little
celebration I did a live stream like
when we're crossing but was more for the
audience than for me and I remember
after two somebody told me oh you got to
be more excited you got to go celebrate
you got to like you got to be more
grateful and like appreciate these wins
and celebrate so I did something with
the audience and I was super to
McDonald's and our french fries yeah no
that was from my book but we still I
still went out and did that's a whole
other story but I still went out and did
something I don't remember what it was
and I remember I'm sitting there like
this is stupid I want to be working like
why am I doing this I don't want to be
celebrating this thing I like I got work
the work is a celebration well but but
people really do turn to you to to not
only learn how to how to grow their
followings grow their impact grow their
mission driven companies through YouTube
and through Tik Tok and social media but
massive players in the industry also
turn to you because you spent what over
a decade now looking at the YouTube
algorithms see I said a decade and year
immediately for our listeners looked up
because go back back if we go back
decade what 2009 2009 I'm trying to what
year is it today yeah it's over it's
been it's been over a decade if we have
new listeners who don't quite realize
the dynamic that's happening right now
EV and I are in here in Toronto in your
studio we've known each other for a very
long time and your very first YouTube
video that that you ever put up onto
YouTube I helped you shoot just a few
blocks south of here yeah well you
didn't help me you shot it I shot it and
I edited it and it took us six weeks to
make if you could believe that but but
people turn to you now because there's
so much um there there's so much
attention there's so much revenue
there's so much that you can do on
YouTube and I think most people don't
even know how to scratch the surface so
if if I'm a business owner if I'm in
sales if I'm in marketing if I'm in
business development and I haven't been
using YouTube first of all why should I
even consider going on to YouTube I
think it starts with the understanding
that people are going to learn YouTube
is the number one learning platform now
if I'm trying to figure out how to do
something I'm not going to the library
I'm not asking my mom like I'm going to
YouTube but like how do I blank and
chances are if you're an entrepreneur
chances are your competition is showing
up or or people who are less skilled
less knowable less less passionate about
the thing than you are are showing up
and you're not and so it's still a wide
open space for most Industries to get
your content on YouTube because in in
advance of any sale you need to educate
your clients and we do this normally as
entrepreneurs like before you sell
something you're answering questions
we're putting stuff on our website we're
educating so YouTube is an education
platform it's not a sales first platform
although we can talk about how to
generate sales from YouTube but the idea
is we're building a brand and we're
educating our c client so that they find
us and we have ideal clients like a
magnet coming to find us and want to do
business with us and so if I'm familiar
with like let's say SEO or content
marketing or if we're running a lot of
AD campaigns that are going to landing
pages or LinkedIn campaigns how should
we be thinking about YouTube is it an
SEO play is it uh an ad play is it
something else so there's three ways to
use it and we can touch on each and you
can dive in deeper into whichever you
want there's the bis Dev show where
we're we're using it just to generate
business for our company we don't care
how well the video does we're not going
after to views at all there's the
demonstrate the process show which we're
using more for conversion than anything
else one is bis one is conversion and
the third is then building our brand
which is what most people think of when
you think of YouTube of making thought
leadership kinds of videos they each
serve a different purpose and depends on
what your goals are with your business
the brand is usually the biggest way to
long-term have success with your company
but it takes a while to build a brand I
mean you've been you've been at it you
know lots of people been at it like it
takes a while to build a brain and a lot
of people fizzle out along the way and
they don't know how to generate
immediate Revenue which is where the
other two shows come in uh so if you
need to make money this year or right
away like in the next three weeks you
can do it through YouTube it's just not
through thought leadership content and
not through brand building content
either right well thought leadership is
the brand building content okay so so
from your point of view being that
thought leader being that educator being
that resource that your prospects and
clients are going to turn to that is the
brand play not what most people are
probably thinking about which is like
let's go hire an influencer let's go
shoot a commercial let's um let's hire
some young person because quote unquote
they know social media better than us
and let's just give them some money and
go make something that's not the brand
playay well okay you threw a couple
things in there like if you're if you're
doing influencer marketing or you're
going to run pre-roll YouTube
commercials cool that's just direct
marketing and so you can do that you
just track does it lead to conversions
for you and that's definitely place
that's not where I would be an expert at
throwing somebody on your team who's
just at a university or whatever that is
usually an attempt to build brand right
we're trying to create our own content
somehow to build brand uh is usually not
a super effective way to do it um but
the direct marketing side is very uh
tangible is huge a lot of people are
doing it a lot of big money is coming
into YouTube because the ad policies are
are stric is but but less strict than
Facebook and Instagram so people people
are getting the higher Roi off of
YouTube ads than they are on Facebook
and Instagram but that's not in my
domain I just see people now with their
ad budgets being shifting a lot towards
YouTube uh but my side is how do you use
organic side to generate business and
again is either like bisb where we need
to generate
sales uh the demonstrate the process
where our problem is conversion or the
thought leadership where we're trying to
build long-term bread let's imagine that
if you're listening to this right now
you may not have jumped on YouTube you
may not have a a whole team helping you
and so but you're probably sitting on a
lot of internal content you're sitting
on your processes you're sitting on your
thinking your people uh you're sitting
on all of the sales tools that you have
all the marketing tools that you have
because because you've been generating
business a DAT is the best place to
start simply taking that stuff you
already have and figuring out a way to
put it on YouTube or is it net new start
something totally fresh and what do we
do depends on what my objective is so
are we trying to generate sales make
some money right now okay then neither
of that's up you want to make money the
next 30 days then you start a bis Dev
show okay give me an example like what
kind of let's let's use a business as an
example okay let's say um architectural
firm okay architectural firm how am I
I'm I'm earning in business I'm selling
architectural services how am I getting
leads currently probably through word of
mouth or RFP from who from uh from from
Property Owners from from
investors uh I'm thinking of the
commercial side at this point I don't
know why but but maybe you're
residential let's go commercial okay so
but but who so who so am I getting it
from mortgage brokers am I getting it
from no it would be it would be like
institutional lenders it would be the it
would be the large holding companies the
the um the the maybe the project
management firms or the contractors
responsible for for building you know
large commercial areas cool now
architectural firm you're probably
geolocated you you're probably not
taking deals on across the country so
let's say it's a a company here in
Toronto we're sitting here in Toronto
Canada right now cool if you already
have an existing business and you
already know your ideal referral lead
sources this is now shooting fish in a
barrel so you launch a show where you go
and you have people who are in Toronto
who are all your ideal referral Partners
so you're going to call all of the
institutional lenders and all of the
Brokers and all of the all these project
managers all of them say I'm starting
this new show talking about
architecture in Toronto I'd love to have
you as a guest on my
podcast and then you go and you film an
episode with them you're kind of giving
away are we're not giving away gold on
Mark jer's podcast are we we are But the
irony is this is turning now into like
like this is essentially I I love
connecting with people to talk about how
to sell more because I want to make
deeper connections within this and I
want to learn more and so this is now
turning into Inception where you were
talking about the very strategy that I
realize we're doing only I didn't talk
to you about the strategy beforehand I
the bis Dev show but you're bringing on
ideal ideal referral sources or it could
be ideal clients for you but ideally
it's referral sources because if you're
an architectural firm and you knew you
knew all of the institutional lenders in
the city and you knew all of the project
managers in the city there's only like a
100 people that you need to know right
if that but if they all knew you and
they loved you how much is you like that
can tenex your business so you start a
show a brand new show hey I'm starting a
brand new show like you don't have to
have some big following if you're trying
to go and get the rock on your show then
okay that's going to be a problem but
you're trying to get project managers
and institutional lenders right people
who never ever in their life been asked
to do an interview at all right whose
own their own marketing sucks probably
right so you're going to go you want to
interview me you want to hear my story
this is amazing right do they want to
sit and talk to you over coffee about
how you might partner together no
they're being pitched all the time but
will they come on your podcast will they
come on your show and talk to you about
architecture in in Toronto like yeah you
want to hear my story let's go and so
the point of that show is to build a
relationship now if you know how much um
a lead is to you you can assign some
budget against it so I I mean I told a
woman to do this um we just had a
session in uh Columbus in the US and she
did it she helped CEOs and after her
show she got a contract for
$700,000 H so like how how many people
subscribe to her Channel nobody it's a
brand new show right it's like it's a
different model we're not trying to be
an influencer we're not trying to be a
thought leader we're just trying to get
to know somebody spend time with them so
could you do it over Zoom yeah you could
do it over Zoom you know Easy Tech
everybody knows how to use zoom now but
if this is a high quality lead for you
that might be worth six or seven figures
to you especially if they're referring
business ongoing to you hire a film crew
spend a th000 bucks go to their office
and spend time with them because the
show might only be an hour but you might
spend three hours with them because
maybe they take you around the office
because maybe they go to lunch with you
and they tell you you know you build and
that's the whole point is you want to
build a deeper relationship it's like
well how do I title it and put it on
that doesn't matter we don't care how
well this video does on YouTube we're
using YouTube as the excuse to build the
relationship H see I say because um to
me the title matters and to me the
viewers matter and to me making sure
that the guest is well presented and and
we build that relationship all those
things matter but perhaps at least no
but then you're wrong and this is like
it doesn't matter because because you
told me that what you cared about is
getting sales I asked you what your
objective was at the beginning I need to
make sales in the next 30 days yes the
title your video doesn't matter because
it doesn't impact your relationship with
them and and it doesn't embarrass them
to go later to YouTube or Google their
name and go that this only got six views
it's a brand new show okay they have
crap marketing yeah this is the best
they have ever looked and will ever look
on anybody's show ever right if you're
so worried about it you could throw an
ad budget against it throw a $100 ads
against that video and it'll have 10,000
views whatever great but that doesn't
that doesn't impact your relationship
like they're going to love you because
you spent two hours with them and you
got to know them and you can cut up the
content and give them little clips for
their Instagram and their YouTube shorts
you're doing their marketing for them so
good so simple anybody can can do it now
would it be embarrassing if you showed
up with your iPhone and you're trying to
hold it out here and it's wobbly yeah
that's embarrassing like that doesn't
represent your brand very at that point
do a zoom call or Riverside instead of
doing that but if this person I'm we're
talking the established business already
right so is it worth $1,000 to go and
spend two hours with IDE an ideal
referral partner for you who might be
worth seven figures to you this year
like that's a probably pretty good
investment now what if uh I remember
working with a client where and this is
more common in I would say larger
companies but I love the idea still
where you invite everyone out for like a
lunch let's say and different
perspectives different people you put
together a round table conversation and
have that filmed now you're getting like
six seven eight people and it's not only
the pull of just the oneon-one but then
you but but the more people you bring
into the round table at a higher caliber
the more of like a little Network a
mastermind a group it feels like uh am I
just making it too complicated now or
all depends on your objective you know I
think if you told me what what I want to
do I want to sell the next 30 days
organizing that it's going to take more
than 30 days the bigger names to get
everybody sit around a table for an hour
is going to be a six-month project to
try to organize now you're the one who
put it all together your scene as the
networking Guru or Maestro but if I'm
trying to sell you or or have you sell
me or refer business to me I want as
much one-on-one time as possible with
you not a group where like you're the
guy who put it together but I want to be
talking to you so there's no excuse
there's no like ah you can't make money
on IG you can't make money on YouTube uh
taking making content you know takes you
a few years to pay off there's no real
excuse for that because it's just about
making the right type of content well
there's lots of excuses but it's an
excuse I don't know what he want it's no
good reason but there's lots of excuses
yeah no there's no good reason for you
not I mean it would be if you don't have
a bit like okay so is that relation ship
worth if a videographer is going be a
th000 bucks to come out right if that
relationship isn't worth a th000 bucks
could you get somebody for 500 yeah
maybe it's a one camera setup but like
yeah you could have somebody you have
somebody with you 500 bucks for the day
and so is that relationship not worth
500 bucks well maybe not like if you're
brand new starting up you don't know how
to generate leads you have no business
you're struggling that the model still
works but I would probably then go to
zoom because the cost infrastructure is
a lot less than if I already had a
business you gave me an example of a su
maybe is say successful but
architectural company like they build a
lot so a thousand bucks to go out to
meet ideal referral partners and spend a
couple hours with them is great do you
have to be good at this or not even no
no you just got to do it yeah okay so
again if you if you don't know what to
do and you don't know how to sell and
you've never closed anybody in your life
well then you're probably not running a
su a business exactly right so it's like
it that's why I ask you the scenario you
said a brain startup like high school
teacher is quitting his day job to try
to do this okay this is an alteration to
the strategy this this podcast called
how to sell more not let's learn how to
sell great so then this is fish in a
barrel like I said at the beginning like
you already know how to build
relationships you've sold something
before you're doing the same thing and
all you're doing is edifying them and
asking them question so if you look at a
format so let's say you're going to talk
for an hour most of what I want to be
about them their story and the questions
are the easiest questions of all time
right you don't need like you mark
Jagger spend days researching somebody
before they come on your show I know
this right and you want to ask like I'm
going to ask like the perfect question
and they're going to know that I
research them and that I read their bio
because on page 48 yeah right there's
that thing I'm going to reference that
I'm going to reference that weird call
back where I'll be like well didn't that
happen in 2012 and they're be like wow
it did happen in 201 you pride yourself
on these things and and there's nothing
wrong with that but doing an interview
like this is easy right like why'd you
get
started and then they tell a story what
made you want to do that what problems
are you seeing right now in the Toral
architecture or real estate market you
asking like five basic questions to
everybody and then they're going to tell
stories and you're just listening right
and again relationship building the more
the other person is talking the more
they think it's a great conversation
right that was a great conversation
right yeah well they did all the Talking
what I would love to do though is make
sure this is what I coach people on in
the middle of your interview make sure
that you ask one question that you can
be an expert at so if you're if you're
an architectural firm in the middle say
you know one of the things we're seeing
in the architecture market right now is
blank what do you think or you say as an
architect what we see is blank right now
what are you seeing and you have a
little mini discussion on that because I
want them to know that you're an
architect not just some Larry King
person coming with another podcast right
that you're actually good at what you do
as an architect and a mini conversation
on that somewhere in the middle and then
at the end you go back to them and what
they're doing and how you can help
promote them and whatever is on their
plans right now like it's very basic
easy eight questions I've noticed as a
branding agency that helps beat a I'm
just Jing I was going to try I was going
to try hitting you with it but then it
just seemed too obvious but but that is
but that's exactly it like as a branding
agency that helps B to B yada y yada
here's what we see what are you seeing
now I know Mark is a branding
agency so good what is your number one
tip or strategy to help us sell more
understand your most important
goal and then create the show that helps
youpl that goal like YouTube can serve
you in a lot of different ways most
people think of it just as a place to be
an influencer and build a brand and and
it is if you want long-term success
building a brand and having people beat
a path to your door is huge but that
doesn't happen in you know 30 days uh so
if your number one goal is I need to
make sales in 30 days cool start a
YouTube show or run Business Development
let's go close we're gonna dig into the
thought leadership stuff now now this is
the type of content that you are
probably best known for helping thought
leaders helping turn business people
into people with followings people with
influence people who can speak and self
from the stage like this is your jam
this is you are known as the master in
this help us understand how we should be
thinking about YouTube now from a
thought leadership point of view this is
what most people think about YouTube I'm
going to be uh talking head I'm going to
have my points I'm going to talk direct
the camera and I'm going to start
sharing my message my story why I do
what do my POV uh Etc and it's the best
way to build a long-term brand the
people are going to YouTube to learn
they see you they see your face they get
to know you they get to trust you
they're watching you every week with new
pieces of content coming up you're going
to be the first person they think of
when they want to hire somebody for
whatever product or Services you
ultimately sell and it leads to
Opportunities you can't even imagine
like if you become the the face of an
industry then you get hired to be the MC
to speak we at events to do brand deals
to sit on people's Boards of directors
to launch products like a lot of
opportunities come Beyond just I get to
make ad revenue from my videos but it it
it is a process to be able to get up to
that point most people quit along the
way because it's hard to build a brand
and it's hard for a couple reasons one
people don't know you yet so you know
you might be a big deal in your industry
and people struggle with with this ego
side of things because you're you're the
big Fisher your company or industry but
online nobody knows who you are hello
right new I don't know who you are it's
hard to start over from scratch and have
the humility to learn a a new skill and
recognize that you're actually not that
big a deal yet and and you have to pick
up the new skill um and second that
you're probably not very good at
speaking on camera or or doing it in a
way that is suitable for YouTube and so
I've had people who are experts at their
industry but then suck on camera and so
but it's fine it's just a skill set
right it's just are you willing to learn
that new skill set and put in the work
to do it or people who are using used to
speaking but don't know how to speak for
a YouTube video and again it's just the
willingness to adopt a new style of
doing things which some people are
willing to do and some people aren't but
in any case it takes time the easiest
way to get started is to figure out what
is content that you would actually love
to do and most people struggle with this
because they pick up content that they
think they should be doing but they
don't actually enjoy and so they're
memorizing scripts or they're getting a
teleprompter and and taking a day to
create a whole you know script out and
reading it off of that and feeling like
they have to do it a certain way then
and then they dread having to go in and
do it and so when I'm helping somebody
and these are like some of the biggest
names in the
industry usually the first question ask
is well what are we trying to sell so
like what's our what's our end goal
because I try to figure which show
should we even be making but if it's
branding and thought leadership then
okay well what would be actually fun for
you to make like what do you mean well
like what what would be fun if you saw
it in your calendar you're going to do
this like you're actually excited to do
it because if you're not having fun
doing it and we've heard that a million
times if you're not passionate about
your work you're going to quit but it
happens so much on YouTube you're not
going to see early results Under The
Branding show and this is a challenge
when you you know that the ROI in your
of your time is high yeah in your
business yes so then commit to making
videos that are not being seen or going
anywhere most people just quit along the
way if you're brand new and starting up
and you have no you have no name and you
have no company and like you don't value
your time very high okay cool you can
mess around on YouTube and do whatever
you don't have a huge opportunity to
cost but if you're already running a
successful business there's High
opportunity cost for how you spend your
time and so they have the patience to
spend three years to build a brand most
people don't do it and if you aren't
having fun doing it then you're
definitely not going to do it it turns
into a nightmare so yeah if you look at
your calendar you see YouTube videos
like oh my God I don't want to do this
then it's over already like it's over
before you started for big names too so
the key is figuring out well what is the
thing that you would love to do that can
help you grow your business that is is
value add and you look see in your
you're actually looking forward to it uh
so there's lots of different types of
thought leadership content that you can
do you don't just have to do direct the
camera memorize script the eight ways of
how to XYZ right you could do an
interview show where people asking you
questions you could do a mentorship show
where people are coming in on your team
and you're helping them improve and grow
you could do a react show where you have
news popping up if you're really
opinionated this is one that I suck at
but other people Crush at because you're
Canadian I'm Canadian and I'm not
opinionated and I see both sides and I'm
too compassionate and so yeah you know
it's like some news article pops up
you're like yeah I see this side and I
see this side that doesn't make for a
great YouTube video but if you but if
you are strongly opinionated that
crushes so pull up a news article and
just talk about it or do a reaction
video and those are usually a lot easier
to put together and create than for you
to have to talk about the eight ways of
how to XYZ some people love that so if
you're a speaker and you love speaking
you can just get in front of the camera
and go then go do that that's a that's
your natural Talent gift amazing but if
you're a CEO at some company and
speaking is not your favorite thing to
do and even worse that you're by
yourself just talking to a camera
usually people don't love that so okay
what kind of show can we create that
would actually be fun for you now now on
that I've run into many different
business owners who go I need to find
someone who can be the face of my
company because they don't even want to
be the face of their company they love
the idea of of of launching mentorship
or training or education or being a
thought leader or content they just
don't want to be the one to do it is
there a situation where you see that
ever working or does it or do this
really come down to this has to come
from leadership I think it depends on
the size of the company you know think
for a lot of entrepreneurial companies
the advantage is the entrepreneur like
why would I work with some small company
instead of a bigger company because the
small company I connect to their story
otherwise it just hire some big company
like why would I hire your agency
instead of some giant agency because of
Mark
Jer you you care your story what you've
been through what you're expert at you
know you if you said I don't want to be
the face I'm going to give it to Susan
on my team to be the face like who the
heck is Susan you have a Susan on your
team I hope not when Susan under the bus
like why is Susan I'm here I'm just
gonna go hire some big company if you're
G to be corporate I'm going to just go
hire a corporate why would I hire you so
it's the ability to tell the story and
usually team is just not as good as the
entrepreneur to tell the story you don't
have to be the most charismatic person
you don't have to be the most
over-the-top person you just have to
deeply connect connect and care about
the mission and purpose of your business
which is usually hard to get
from uh a non entrepreneur founder
inside the company it's it's possible
but it's usually boring it's usually
corporate it's usually not heart-c
centered and to make this easier for
people who may be just getting started
and and uncomfortable with it can you
we've talked about a bunch of strategies
but I suppose you can go and hire a host
to interview you to pull out of you the
very best bits of of of your responses
right yeah if you'd rather talk to
somebody than have somebody interview
you they don't even have to be on camera
they could have just be somebody feeding
you
questions you know um even when I
started filming here for my Channel at
my studio my one of my first camera guys
my first real camera guy that I
committed energy to um was he had a lot
of negative views on things and so I
would I would make my video and then ask
him for his reaction and he said yeah
but what about this stuff it's like
people even think that way what but it
made my video better because I could
then respond to his response now he
never made it into any of my videos but
he made my videos better because I got
to see his reaction so you could have
somebody there's there's lots of formats
for this right a lot of you like joa
willing has a co-host but the guy is
asking him and feeding him questions um
some people just like the Andrew H will
just get in front of a camera for 3
hours with a sack of papers and just go
but he's a professor and he's making
professorial kind of videos um so it
doesn't have to people think that you
have to be Tony Robbins up there and you
know preaching your message you don't
like most if you look at your industry I
don't know who's listening to this a lot
of people in your industry are pretty
boring yes so you don't have to be the
most charismatic person they're not
buying we're talking about how to sell
more right so they're not buying from
you because of the b-roll and the fancy
music and the graphic package they're
buying from you because of your story
and your humanity and who you are right
now if you are in the Fitness business
okay you have to you should be fit you
know if you're in the beauty business
you should look good right but if I'm in
uh the you know marketing business or
I'm a printer or I'm a whatever company
I'm not I'm not hiring you because of
how good your video looks and you don't
want to look like crap um and I don't
expect you to be the the most
charismatic person in the world I just
need to see that you are good at what
you do I have a friend in Florida who's
a probate lawyer Al nicoletti he started
a show a few years ago and it's like
probate like it's it's it's the most
it's super super boring and lawyers are
super boring like for the most they're
normally yeah but but this forced him I
I would say that this forced him to be
more outgoing realize that that no one
really cares about probe but when they
need probate they need it and if you
don't know what probate is you you can
look it up because I didn't even until I
talked to him uh and he never talks
about probate ever because nobody cares
nobody's interested in and it doesn't
matter but he's in season four of his
show his network is huge and he's super
comfortable on camera now a few se a few
years in uh he's lost tons of weight
because because he saw himself on camera
and realized oh this is not how I want
to be so he lost like I don't know 150
pounds got super super fit his business
is taking off and it's changed his
entire life
a podcast I like like it's bizarre to me
how how much it can shift just making
yourself a thought leader putting
yourself out in the spotlight and having
to stand for something and and be that
person but have you seen all of the soft
benefits as well on with the people that
you're working with in terms of how just
pushing yourself out there makes you
more well-rounded as a communicator a
leader or whatever it might be anytime I
think you go through something difficult
you come out as a stronger person as a
change person and so for a lot of people
public speaking is
what like the most terrifying thing to
do and now we're not just public
speaking we're recording it it's on
YouTube for anybody around the world to
forever right and so like that that is
that that takes a lot of Courage at the
beginning to get going a lot of these
fears are are just in our head like most
fears you know you think uh I'm G to
make this video what what like a you
think a million people are going to
watch your first video of you sharing
about probate law like nobody's even
watching your first video dude you know
it's like it's not a not that big a deal
right we're worried that people are
going to watch it but then we're also
worried that nobody's going to watch it
right like what's the point of doing
this nobody watches it so like what do
you want you want people to watch it you
people not to watch it we stress out
about these things but I think anytime
you go through something difficult like
making a YouTube channel like doing a
triathon like whatever you you become
stronger you become better you you
challenge and grow like shout out to
your old podcast and we do hard things
like you you change and grow when you do
something hard so definitely I see I
mean I see it a lot but I I don't think
that's the Reon why you want to get into
starting a YouTube channel it's a
definitely a side benefit but the the
point is we want to sell more like why
are we here we you have a business and
when you have a giant impact you're able
to sell a whole lot more and again as
you continue to build your brand so many
other opportunities will come up to you
that you can't even realize or think
about right now I mean Alex Heros is a
great case study example where he he was
building all his marketing direct
marketing having you know whatever you
know hundred million net worth Etc and
then saw that uh one of the Kardashians
had more net worth than he did it's like
how is this possible like I'm so much
better as a business person and this
person and he go well because they have
brand and you don't because you're just
doing direct marketing and so you need
to build a brand and that's what pushed
them over the edge to say I need to go
and build a brand because ultimately I'm
going to sell way more if people know me
and know me and like me more than just
they saw one of my advertisements and
that has been a big shift in the
industry where we've seen lots of people
move over from direct marketing starts
to now building a brand going back to
like Seth Goden and then Dean graziosi
and Brendon brashard like people who cut
their teeth on Direct Market a big part
of that was the fact that the platforms
that used to be so cheap to buy
attention and awareness for that allowed
you to have really strong Returns on
just direct response have become far
more expensive and so and far more
competitive so it's almost like the
market has has priced itself out where
brand is one of the only solutions I
think you still make a lot of money with
direct marketing like you have to have a
good product a good offering of course
but there's still huge opportunities
especially on YouTube there's still
giant companies go go to YouTube and do
uh go Incognito and look at channels how
many giant companies have you seen there
you're not seeing most of the big
companies with the huge budgets they're
still spending on TV like you're not
seeing the huge campaigns come in at
least on YouTube that's what I'm more an
expert at uh so there's still giant
opportunities but it's not it's not that
um I don't think it's been priced out of
the market I think you have a good
opportunity you can still make a ton of
money brandage is better brandage is
better like long-term brandage is better
think again what are your goals what you
know what's your timeline you said I
have to make money in the next three
months brand is going to be a waste of
time and for most entrepreneurs brand is
a waste of time at the beginning brand
is a waste of time like if you're just
starting the company don't focus on
brand you need sales but longer term
right if you're looking out three-year
window 5year window 10e window like
brand is the only thing that matters
like you'll sell way more through brand
than you will through paperclick or any
kind of direct marketing and so you
mentioned early on that that people are
uncomfortable going from being a market
leader being the CEO being the expert
being the person in their space to
suddenly being a novice and it's
uncomfortable you know I see this all
the time with my podcast and with other
things I get pitched people to come on
my show and it's like this is the person
who built a million dooll lawn care
company and I go okay right like good
for you but but I don't understand why
you're any different than any other
business owner who's built a million
dollar company so bougie now Mark
apparently now but I want more of a
pitch like I want to know more like I
want to know more about it's just not
enough to have built a million-dollar
company cool what else and so you move
from your industry to suddenly realizing
oh you know like maybe what I've done is
not that special I remember having the
the head of HR for Chick-fil-A get
pitched to me cool you're the head of HR
for Chick-fil-A and you wrote a book
like I I guess if I was in that space
it'd be interesting to me but it's just
not that big of a pull like I just it
just didn't hit me and so you said it
takes a few years to be able to really
be able to get good at this to push
through to ramp up to get comfortable
what kpi should we be focusing on like
like how do we measure progress in winds
and does that change from un certain
Milestones or or as we move from year
one to year two to year three just so we
don't give up so we realize we are in
fact making progress which what should
we be looking at so would split that
into into two buckets where the first is
what you're talking about is like being
a guest in other people's shows because
that's much more of a campaign around
something right like I'm trying to
launch my book or I've got this thing
that I'm promoting that you hire a PR
firm and you go on a bunch of shows cool
that's not really building a long-term
brand you're kind of if somebody wants
to come on your show they're trying to
connect to your brand and your audience
but they're not really doing long-term
value for their brand so much the
challenge that I see is when people are
they've done more than a million doll
they've had $100 million do they sold
their business for for a billion dollars
plus these are real people who then they
have to start over and they don't want
to start they're used to team they're
used to everything being done for them
they're used to
people treating them with tons of
respect and like they worked their way
up for 10 years to build this thing and
now they sold it or they're at the top
of the mountain it's like nobody cares
about you online like what do you mean I
got five views on that video right how
do I get there faster well and they
don't want to hear the dancers is them
like no like you said
Su right like that's the problem right
that's that's honestly why people will
value talking to me because I'll tell
the person who's running a $200 million
company that they suck with their
YouTube videos because everybody else is
trying to Plate them and like no like
dude you suck you see how you did that
there that's terrible look at your like
your retention is going to be ass
nobody's going to watch this thing you
need to get better at this thing while
still paying respect to like what they
did but a lot of people will have a they
just have a really hard they just expect
to win they're so used to winning that
now they can't handle losing but it's
like it's a brand new thing why do you
expect to just win out of the gate and
that expectation of winning and more
even fear of losing means they don't
start the number of people sitting on
shows sitting on channels sitting on
ideas and just not starting because they
don't want their first show to suck like
it's G to suck anyway I mean you could
throw eye budget or whatever against it
but it's still going to suck so we just
need to start getting going people need
the reassurance so in terms of kpis to
look at um I would just expect the first
10 shows to suck like just expect them
to write them off it's a write off no
matter what you do to try to make it
great cool like don't even watch them
back it's a complete write off we're
just getting we're just getting to the
gym we're just starting to get some reps
this show is my fourth show I've
launched I've been podcasting for eight
years um so this is my fourth show and
part of me secretly is like we're just
going to get them out and then the other
part because you know we're building an
audience and everything else and moving
people over from my other shows but the
other part of me is like these are so
good it's a shame that no one is like oh
these are so good I want people I want
people to hear these I want people to
see these These are so good it's good
but Mark in five years will look back at
this one and say that wasn't that good
like what was your first podcast the
NATO corporate podcast that was a
disaster you hated that talk about a
train wreck of a podcast and you loved
you loved that title Noto corporate yeah
yeah not just the title you love some of
the episodes I remember like giving you
a hard time on some like Mark this is
just a complete still up on YouTube
Somewhere train wreck it was it was bad
now but looking back now you can oh
they're terrible right but in the moment
you thought they were great you're like
this is really good yeah and then my
second podcast that we did together
something to proove podcast yeah that
had some pretty bumpy episodes yeah
that's fine that's Ling you got you got
way better as a podcast host with we do
her things way better even even within
episode one
versus way better 160 or something Epis
years in for sure so yeah and and now
there's new show great cool I mean
awesome it's you're you're you're
evolving and getting way better each
time but you're still going to be better
in five years and now and so who cares
with the first 10 episodes
of of this one on sales right I think it
doesn't matter oh they're so good but
but you have to be willing to because if
you're so attached to the first 10
working and then they don't then you
stop like why are we doing this this was
time we write off the first 10 but but
if it's going to take three years again
what how are we measuring how we in
gaining this I want to focus on the gain
not the Gap falling short of our of our
expectations yeah I have my own thoughts
on on that on that we'll save that for
another episode I think if you actually
said this is GNA take me three years
yeah everything else
changes because if you're thinking three
years you don't care about where you're
at at month
one like what are we measuring okay you
can measure views you can measure
attention you can measure subscribers
you can measure comments you can measure
email signups you can measure did we hit
the top Apple iTunes whatever guess
we're talking about YouTube he's making
fun of me now like 60 on the whatever
like it doesn't matter but but fine if
you need that cool great you know but
like if you're thinking three-year
window like I'm not even going to look
at things for three years or not not
judge myself uh too harshly for three
years of course you're going to start
looking at the main metrics everybody
else looks at the big numbers of views
the subscribers and and then the the
qualitative of like this changed my life
or this made me a million dollars or
whatever but the biggest one is just the
patience to know that I'm I'm committing
to this for three years I'm going to do
a 100 episodes and then committing this
for three
years is there a certain point in your
experience where it stops being fun and
it turns into work yeah that's why you
got to
Pivot you got to Pivot away because you
got you got there are times where where
I go you know with with things I've done
where I was like this is the mark of a
true professional right it's not always
going to be fun it's not always going to
be like like like showing up and doing
what you need to do is a mark of a true
professional
yeah so we're sitting here in my studio
in Toronto I'm running a three-day
Mastermind I've got my film crew here
with us so as we're getting all this you
know gear and audio and everything I've
just done six different one-on ones with
people I have dinner tonight and then a
giant two-day event over the next two
days plus you've made like 14,000 videos
or something I'm sitting here like with
a headache from from from doing all the
shows I don't really feel it but I will
after and why why I invited you this it
wasn't even that you asked me it's like
Mark I I'm looking at my window I've got
an extra little chunk here that I have I
have my crew and we don't have uh
anybody to talk to like do you want do
you want the spot before I fill it up
and you said yes I was like so we're
here doing this but this doesn't work
like even though I've got a a headache
this is not this is fun and I think the
second that you look at your calendar
and say this is work on a oneoff sh
whatever you didn't sleep well you don't
like the guest whatever cool but if
that's consistently happening you have
you'll never win doing work that you
hate like you'll never crush it on your
podcast if you if you show up every day
and you don't like the podcast you don't
like the guest you don't like what
you're doing which means you have to
Pivot it may mean you I don't know the
back story behind stopping we do hard
things and moving to to the what's the
new sales one called what's this one
called how to sell more how to sell more
right great there's a story right I mean
at some point you stopped liking doing
that it wasn't working or or that ran
out of time whatever but it wasn't okay
that's it I'm done all podcasting I'm
never talk anybody again I'm just going
to go and do something else like no I'm
going to laun a new show and so
everything has a time in place but yeah
if I look at my calendar and I and
I'm consistently not liking when
something shows up then you have to move
on because you're not going to win doing
work that you hate so good okay let's
wrap this one up we're talking about
thought leadership number one sales tip
number one sales strategy to sell
more tell me what you
believe about something in your industry
that that other people don't believe so
when you're talking to customers you
know what the somebody's already
successful in business you you're you're
asking an answering the same 30
questions on repeat right there's like
not that many new situations and you're
telling your client something that they
they don't they don't know or they don't
believe right they knew everything that
you knew they wouldn't be asking you
questions so there's something that you
know that they don't believe is possible
and you're showing them oh this is
possible so leave your videos with a
powerful opinion what do you believe
about X that other people don't believe
and start the video with that and if you
can organize your videos that way you
have a lot more left as opposed to how
most people start a video which is hey
guys welcome back it's me so excited to
be here happy Tuesday welcome back I
don't even know who you are what I'm
being welcome back to and then they
leave so what do you believe that other
people don't believe about your industry
that your clients need to know and
that's the first thing out of your mouth
when you press record what episodes are
these for your show I don't know the the
release the release number yet how many
have you done like roughly we launched
with five on day one and then over the
and then by Sunday we'll have hit 18 so
we're launching with 18 that were
pre-recorded and pre-created okay and
then we're doing two per week after that
so for the first two weeks 18 went out
and then who was number one who was
number one Jeff larner was the first
episode oh okay why was I number one uh
because I respect your time and we're
recording after we've already launched
the podast unbelievable I would have
said yes the sky okay keep going I
honestly didn't know how on board you
would be with with with the how to sell
more podcast this is how to sell more
guys you have to ask okay how do you
sell more ask ask people I didn't know
how on board you'd be well did you ask
don't take the yes away from somebody
else ask that's how you sell more
episode done if if if this is the first
time you've heard Evan on this podcast
or if this happens to be the first
podcast that you're listening to from us
the reason it's a little more casual
Evan and I have been good friends and we
known each other since 2007 uh and so
that's why there's going to be a little
bit more banter perhaps 2007 yeah wow
now we're going to talk about conversion
content what is conversion content what
is that on YouTube I mean I can I can
guess but show me the process of you
doing the thing that you're great at O
Okay so this is this is great for
conversion and it's usually the easiest
content to make as well so what are you
doing already day-to-day with your
clients that you can show me the thing
that you're doing instead of just trying
to talk about the thing that you're
doing because most of us are afraid to
talk about the thing we're uncomfortable
in front of the camera all the reasons
why we don't get started on YouTube but
you're an expert at at the thing
hopefully like if you're listening to
the show you already know how to do
something so instead of telling me show
me right I mean this is sales 101 show
don't tell so you know example I was
figuring out my studio at home to figure
out the the sound paneling and how to
get it all quiet because it's a big
basement and you know no carpets and
just e happens when you have marble
flooring and glass doors and and
hardwood everywhere so Echo Mania so I
we're looking at different companies of
like who do I hire who's good and I came
across uh a company J A here in Toronto
and all of their websites are just okay
and all of their like all of the
competitors is like sound installation
guys right like they're not marketing
guys
but he had a video and it's him saying
hey it's Jake from Jad and uh here we go
and it's not it's not super well done
and he's not like the most articulate
guy and he's not it's not fancy edited
but he's in an empty room and then he
goes into a room with his sound paneling
and you can just hear on the audio the
difference and you can hear his
excitement for like how much he L like
like geeking out on the side like do you
guys hear this like you how hear how
quiet oh my God it's crazy quiet in here
like he he's just actually not the most
extroverted way but you could tell that
this guy just loves sound right and like
I like this guy I'm going to hire this
guy right and from that one YouTube
video I don't know how much I sent with
him that's how you found your vehicle
rapping company too right yeah I mean so
the the the sound guy maybe I spent 5K
with I don't know we're probably going
to do some more with him the the the
rapping company also has a YouTube
channel of showing them wrapping cars uh
but again people are going to learn on
YouTube and how do I tell you apart from
other people it's not that so much
they're finding your video as lead gen
like I didn't find his video by typing
in Toronto sound proof F or whatever I
found his website but on his website was
his content that video and that one
video made me want to hire him and so
it's easy content to make because for
him to get in front of a camera and talk
for 20 minutes about sound I'm sure he
would like have a heart attack and not
want to do it for him to walk through a
room and talk about why what he did in
here and how special it is is a lot
easier and so we're thinking about
content that can yes go up on Youtube
channel it might lead to some Legion it
might lead to a little bit of branding
but the main point is for people who are
finding you to convert them to want to
work with you so that's a brick and
mortar kind of like old school business
kind of example I've got an even better
example I think so there's there's a
channel out of
Australia and they are
industrial uh it's like an industrial
metal shop
now I wish I could remember the name of
the company but I but I but it comes up
in my feet all the time I think it's uh
csse industrial Australia or something
like why does an industrial metal
company show up in your feet all the
time that's well so here's the thing
somehow I found it but this whole
channel it's a husband and a wife uh
they're in maybe their 30s the wife does
all the video work the husband literally
like if if you thought of of a guy
working in mining who was a welder and a
lathe operator which is what he is not
necessarily um the most comfortable on
camera but he's he is so detailed and
knowledgeable about his craft I have
somehow become addicted to watching a
guy who pulls off I don't know boring
things off of excavators for mining in
Australia to watch him recreate or
rebuild these things in each step of the
way he explains the detail he explains
the care he explains why he's doing it
this way and saving the customer $5,000
and $5,000 there and you just can't like
like you can't help but but like this
guy and respect this guy and realize how
much he knows and therefore if I was
looking for these services and no one
else is going to this detail I don't I
can't trust that anyone knows as much as
this guy but but just by the fact that
they set up a camera and his first few
videos were just them setting up a
camera I I don't think he even talked to
camera for the first 20 or 30 episodes
and then eventually now all these years
later they have something like 500 or
600,000 followers and they're there you
can see their shop growing you can see
that that that they're building their
business which is this industrial
business simply because they took the
time to show every step of the process
and how much he cares about it yeah and
that's a lot easier content for him to
make than to talk about how he's going
to make these things happen right it's
just how do you talk about it's
impossible he could try to draw it on a
whiteboard or something but like just
just take me and show me right it may
not be the now maybe if you's had that
many subscribers now he's invested more
into the production than what he had at
the beginning but doesn't have to be
very high production especially at the
start because you're not a video
production company like if you're a
video production company your stuff
better look good I mean why am I going
to hire a crappy video production
company right but if you're if you're a
a sound company or you're a Industrial
Metal Company whatever I don't expect
like top tier video production you know
so those are maybe some old school
examples if you go into more digital
stuff or like coaching for example if
you're a coach coach show me your
coaching like this is a big problem a
lot of coaches make thought leadership
content where they're saying here are
the eight ways to overcome XYZ okay
instead of doing that show me you
coaching somebody if your gift is
coaching coach yeah this is this is hard
though like I'm thinking right now of a
project we've been working on for nine
months that I'm not really allowed to
talk about but it's a very complex
qualitative market research study for
professional association that is having
Mass like just eye opening massive
changes this this work we've been doing
I confident will will save this
Association over the next five years and
completely change their
industry and I just I like we can't we
can't show it we can't talk about it we
can't make videos on it we can't reveal
anything about it there are a lot of
people who maybe they're not under an
NDA like we are or something but there
are a lot of people who do work where
they just go like how do how do we give
people on board with this yeah but you
don't even need you don't even need to
show current clients right like you
don't need to make content with current
clients to show that you're good at
marketing like it's great to have case
studies but coach so if you're if you're
doing
marketing tear apart somebody's
campaign whatever big campaign is going
on right now tear it apart and say like
here's all the things that they doing
wrong here's their Facebook ad here's
their landing page it doesn't connect
here's what I mean whatever you're going
to be an expert at show me the process
instead of you saying here are the eight
ways to launch a new brand show me
somebody whose brand came out and tear
it apart not just for what's ideally
you're talking about what went wrong not
hear all the things that they did right
like okay that's cool but like what what
would you fix right that because that's
really where you show your expertise
like how would you fix this especially
if there's some big campaign that a lot
of people have seen as a success it's
okay it was pretty good and you know
what here are the five things that need
to be fixed one of the ways I met Tom
bill you was I made a a YouTube video
breaking down his channel I if remember
that it was him and I think Eric Thomas
I forget who it was I looked at him and
somebody else's Channel and I broke it
down and said you know and I'm not so
I'm not super negative it's constructive
feedback um because I love Tom but you
know here's what he did right but here's
what I would fix and the number one
comment was Tom like saying thank you so
much for all those valuable feedback and
that's how we started to get to know
each other so cool you can't talk about
this Association whatever you know boo
boo for them great like you could have
give them Mar it's like they're just bad
marketers if they're not willing to have
their name be spread out more right it's
like you want people to tell their story
like you telling them you telling the
world about XYZ their company their
Association is good for them right they
don't understand that whatever I don't
want to trct your client but I kind of
want to do they're good people don't do
that oh they're great people terrible
marketers right like if I'm them if I'm
you or I'm me talking to them like guys
this is why I'm here to help you because
you provide an amazing service but you
can't Market if your life depends on you
and like this is a wrong decision right
you should you should be allowing people
to anyway we're not going to talk about
that like if you're a coach show me your
coaching or if you sell a program like
go to the digital economy now like you
sell some program where students are
coming through and feeling great so
coach a student who's completed your
program or The Graduate it a year with
you have them come and then do a show
with you so what happens like if
somebody's gone through your oneye
coaching program or online training or
whatever great after the year you have
them come on and be a guest on your show
and how's that show going to open you
say well here's Johnny and Johnny just
spend a year in my program now we're
talking about the program without
talking about the program yeah Johnny's
say oh my God your program is so great
right thank you so much like what are
the Chan he's gonna come on and say hey
your program is trash right like he's
probably gonna say if he does he cancel
the episode but he's probably going to
say saying good things right so now
Johnny's saying great things about our
program and say well okay well how can I
help like what else can I do to help you
now Johnny and then you spend the next
25 minutes coaching him through whatever
he needs help with that video can live
on YouTube it could be could be a
branding play it could help start to
generate a little bit of traffic for you
but that video hits your landing page
for your offer huh so now when I'm
looking at you I sign up for this
program or not I don't know right like
now you have a video not of testimonials
yeah which are fine and studies but now
I get to see you actually helping
somebody like oh my God this Mark guy
like really cares and really knows his
stuff so I I'm very often doing like
strategy sessions with people especially
through my network you know I'm part of
private Mastermind groups and if you're
in a mastermind group with me then we
set up a call and and I'm just going to
go ahead and give you everything it's
not a sales call or anything I've never
thought to record those and I had one
last week and um you know there were
four people on the call and me and um I
really checked challenged their thinking
and I know I really helped them it only
took like 35 minutes and they were like
stop Mark you you've given us enough to
do now uh I never thought to record that
I wonder if it would change the dynamic
in the conversation though if they knew
they were being recorded for some people
but a lot of people they forget that the
cameras are on like once they're once
they start rolling or if you're doing it
over Riverside or something there's like
basically the same thing they're talking
to the zoom your goal is not to
humiliate them and make them look like
idiots like right hopefully right so
that's
good no but some people like the whole
point is to try to get a gotcha moment
and try to make them look stupid uh so
you know that's fine and a lot of people
would would value it you know so yeah I
would again they'll take the yes away
from somebody you know you're you're
you're worried that they're going to say
no well maybe they'll say
yes right so now you have great content
to see how great you are at what you do
how do we get people to to watch this
simply record it drop it on your landing
pages drop it as social proof drop it on
on whatever inbound Source people happen
to be hitting yeah so again the goal is
how do I sell more that's what this
episode or this show is all about this
is about converting so we have people
who are hitting our landing page but
they're not buying as much as they
should okay so how do we get them to
convert more well let's see a video of
you doing the thing that you're so great
at and so if I hit your landing page for
your for your marketing offer and then I
saw 10 videos of you coaching people
that you package and you you know the
opening is like oh my God Mark I didn't
even think about that like that's the
opening of the video and I get to see
you in your Prime doing amazing things
like I want I want that I don't even
know what you know how to do I just I
want want that too yeah like what what
is I want that for me I want that for my
sales pag I want to feel that I want to
feel that I want to feel that thing that
that guy is feeling when he's with Mark
so I'm gonna hire Mark you know what's
the whole thing with sales I don't have
to believe that I can do it I just have
to believe that you believe that I can
do it right it's like if I'm going to I
don't have to believe that my marketing
is going to be amazing I just have to
believe that you believe my marketing is
going to be amazing and if you believe
my Mark is going to be amazing my belief
is not in myself but in you so how do I
believe in you super heady he used to
used to accuse me of being super heady
with things I'm super heady that was
super heady is it yeah I I would I would
say maybe it's the same thing or not but
are you trying to say like you don't
have to be the fastest runner when
you're running away from a bear you just
have to be faster than no your friend no
no no this is sales this is sales
psychology when you're when you're
talking to
somebody they one of the biggest reasons
why people don't move forward in the
sales conversations because they don't
believe they can do it they might
believe that other people can get
results but they don't believe that they
can do it they don't believe it's
possible for them and so they don't
they're afraid they don't take action
they don't put they don't take the first
payment they don't take the first step
and so understand that it's actually not
their lack of belief in themsel it's
their lack of belief in you so if they
they believe that you can help them get
the result they'll move forward so they
can have all the lack of belief in thems
as long as they believe in you okay and
so if I'm watching your I'm on your
channel like I need I know I need
marketing I don't know like I suck at
marketing I'm this stupid Association
we're going under anyway
and amazing people we we're raing
impactful work Mar is just so bad I am
so excited to be a part of this project
I have to say that I have to cuz it's
true no I know I believe you I mean I
believe you we do we do lifechanging
work but our Market is just terrible and
we're never going to get it and so we're
like kind of like a lost cause we're
basically going under and we're not
we're not going to do
this but I look at your stuff and like
all I have to believe is that Mark
believes that we can fix because you
said like we're going to change this
whole thing for them and your confidence
makes them confident that's it they may
have no confidence in themselves maybe
they try 18 other agencies they all
failed because they don't let anybody
use case studies and you know it's just
it's been a training Rec of people that
they hired right but you have confidence
coming in to say no no no like this is
going to work we can do this and it's
your confidence that they're buying into
so it's your belief and your ability to
do this even if they suck and have no
belief and so that's what conversion
content does is it helps transfer that
belief to say I don't think we can do
this but you know what I think Mark can
do this for us now there's a reason why
everybody listening knows why you speak
at all of these private events why some
of the largest Brands and some of the
largest thought leaders turn to you to
help them run their channels and to be
able to really make the most out of
YouTube because I've known you for a
very long time and I feel like I know
most of what you're saying but the way
you're saying it today is hitting me
differently than like reading a YouTube
Playbook or anything else this is like
such this is again there's no
excuses there's excuses there's no
reason not to work this into your
business all depends on what your goal
is what are you trying to accomplish
there's three different types of content
you can make that serve different
purposes so the the bis Dev show is I
need to generate immediate revenue and I
want to double my business in the next
year cool like you can you can do that
with bisf content the thought Le show
content is I'm trying to build a brand
that then over the next 3 to 10 years
brings in so much clients and cash flow
and revenue for me that I don't even
have to do much of the other marketing
cool that's a different reason and then
today's episode is about converting and
making easy content by showing what
you're an expert at and transferring
your belief into people that okay I
think this is the guy for me because
you'll you'll as as good of a presenter
you are and I've seen you present and
speak and I've had you inside my private
groups of sharing wisdom you're better
at the client coaching than you are at
presenting and if if I had to put my
money on okay I have one opportunity for
Mark to make this big pitch to a client
I'd much rather it be this collaboration
between you two where you're going back
and forth and coaching than you going up
and pitching for an hour which may not
be everybody's skill set but it is yours
like it you have to be a good coach
which you are a lot of people they're
afraid of being exposed and not knowing
what the questions are to be so they
just stick to the pitch but if you're
actually a good coach and good in the
consultative sales process that's a way
better thing to be able to do and so
great you're already that's how you're
getting sales awesome now film it I
don't know that you're good at
that till I see it show don't tell so
for this episode your number one tip
your number one strategy to sell more
show me the process of the thing that
you're great at and film it to see me go
again one-on-one with Mark drer check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there hey there I'm Mark
Trager and I sit down with Evan
carmichel in a 10p part series because I
was able to build uh an over million
dollar a year in business